الشاب خالد كما لم ترونه من قبل موقف محرج
لجورج قرداحي في جرش وسميه الخشاب تشعل
منصات التواصل بالرقص تفاعل لا يخلو من
الانتقادات اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
تجاوزت عائدات فيلم باربي المليار دولار
عالميا خلال ثلاثه اسابيع وذلك وفقا
لتقديرات شركه وانر براذرز الرسميه وبذلك
اصبحت المخرجه غريتا غرويج اول مخرجه في
العالم تحقق هذا الرقم من الايرادات في
شباك التذاكر على الاطلاق مصريا قاربت
عائدات فيلم بيت الروبي من بطوله كريم عبد
العزيز وكريم محمود عبد العزيز ال 116
مليون جنيه مصري اتصالات السينما العربيه
وذلك بالتزامن مع انطلاق عروضه اتصالات
السينما التركيه وسط توقعات بان تكسر
ايرادات بيت الروبي الرقم القياسي الذي
حققه فيلم كيرا والجن وبلغ 120 مليون جنيه
العام الماضي وتحتدم المنافسه حاليا في
دور العرض المصريه والعربيه على ايرادات
شباك التذاكر بين الفيلمين المصريين مرعي
البريمو لمحمد هنيدي وعزيرو لمحمد رمضان
وتشير التقديرات الاوليه الى تفوق هنيدي
في الايرادات على رمضان وذلك بعد ايام
قليله من انطلاق عروض الفيلم
ومن السينما الى موسم الحفلات والمهرجانات
الموسيقيه في العالم العربي خلال شهر
اغسطس وفي السعوديه اطل الشاب خالد كما لم
ترونه من قبل زي السعودي وذلك خلال احيائه
حفل الموسيقيا ضمن فعاليات موسم الجيمرز
في الرياض واحيت المطربه المصريه انغام
ليله صوت مصر في جده واختتم مهرجان جرش
للثقافه والفنون فعالياته الاسبوع الماضي
بحفل جماهري للمطرب اللبناني وائل كفوري
وشهد المهرجان حدثا طريفا تداوله متابعوه
منصات التواصل على نطاق واسع حينما اخطا
الاعلامي اللبناني جورج قرداحي باسم
المطرب المصري هاني شاكر حينما قام بتقديم
التكريم له في المهرجان
[تصفيق]
وكالعاده استقبل جمهور مهرجان جرش المطرب
السوري جورج وسوف بحفاوه كبيره واختار ابو
وديع لاول مره ان يطل على جمهوره من وراء
ستاره سوداء وتداول متابعون على منصات
التواصل ان السبب يعود لوضعه الصحي الحالي
وفي سوريا اختتمت فعاليات مهرجان ليالي
قلعه دمشق بحفل للمطرب التونسي صابر
الرباعي وكانت الفنانه اللبنانيه كالولو
سماحه من نجوم المهرجان وطلبت من الجمهور
السوري الوقوف دقيقه صمت على ارواح ضحايا
انفجار مرفا بيروت حيث تزامن حفلها في
دمشق مع الذكرى الثالثه الانفجار الماساوي
فرح اطلب منكم دقيقه
واصدرت المطربه اللبنانيه ماجده الرومي
بالتزامن مع هذه الذكرى اغنيه بعنوان
عندما ترجع بيروت عن قصيده للشاعر السوري
الراحل نزار قباني
[موسيقى]
في مياه البحر او ياتي مع الموج الحساد
ومن الاصدارات الموسيقيه الجديده التي
حققت التفاعل على منصات التواصل في العالم
العربي الاسبوع الماضي ذوي غنائي بعنوان
الحب الابدي يجمع بين المطربين ماجد
المهندس واصاله من كلمات زوجها فائق حسن
واشعلت سميه الخشاب بنصات التواصل بالرقص
والتفاعل الذي لم يخلو من الانتقادات بعد
اصدارها اغنيه جديده بعنوان اركب على
الموجه محتاج البحر يفرفشني
انا نفسي واركب على
ومما تفاعل معه متابعه منصات التواصل في
مصر رقصه للفنانه ناديه الجندي على انغام
اغنيه بنت الايه لتامر حسني خلال احدى
حفلاته في الساحل الشمالي